well you can't have a stadium without
amenities and allegiance stadium
will have some of the best in the
business if you're going to draw
65 000 fans well you better have some
culinary options
for the hungry audience sports director
chris matthews went on the taste of
allegiant tour today and chris what do
you have
well thank you very much christian i'll
tell you what you have to have some
concessions in today's world of sports
not only sports but the concerts and the
other events that will be happening
here inside allegion stadium we might
mention that over the next six weeks
they will have seven events inside here
so this place is going to be really busy
so you got to have the concessions there
are over 30 concessionaires in here and
of course
you can see where my shoulder this
little event is just getting underway
this is kind of a
uh introduction to all the different
concessionaires that are here we
mentioned there are over 30
top class food this is the champions
club this is where you'll see big
pictures of the 1976 super bowl
champions
the 1980 super bowl champions the 1983
super bowl
champions they have the lombardi
trophies here this will be a special
special room
for all those uh fans who come to
allegiant stadium to see
the raiders and of course other events
that will happen here there's an event
this weekend here at legion stadium
kind of a techno event so a lot of
people garth brooks is going to be here
later on
so you have to have it it's very
important to have those concessions
and that's what they're talking about
here you have charles woodson hall of
famer former raider he's here
he has a wine business so in fact he's
speaking right now up there at the
podium so
charles woodson's here you got president
mark madane with the raiders he's here
all these different concessionaires and
really what it's like it was like a
five-star resort people wanted to come
here it wasn't hard recruiting
they had to turn people away from a
legion stand so many people wanted to
get their fingerprint
and their concession inside of legion
stadium so we're gonna have much more
coming up
at five o'clock in fact we're going to
speak with mark boden the president
we'll speak with charles woodson
the hall of famer who's as we mentioned
now in the wine business so he's excited
about this place
as many many raiders fans are so much
more coming up at five and at six
we'll see what's going on here and just
why and how important
are concessions to the business of
stadiums really
really important might also mention that
they uh they said that the food here
isn't your normal hot dogs and popcorn
lots and lots of options here at
allegiance team so much more coming up
at five o'clock
and also at six reporting live from the
bowels of the legion stadium chris
matthews eight sports now back to